good afternoon everyone and shut up my
name is dr. gears and I will be taking
your elector today no questions please
BSEP in the spotlight today is scp-963
object class Euclid special containment
procedures scp-963 - one is to be given
into the care all current d-class level
operative as well as personnel
classified as dr. brights assistant this
assistant is to be chosen by Oh fight
for loyalty to the foundation as well as
psychological stability there's a couple
of scored out things here the first
thing is scp-963 is to be attached to
the subjects forehead or the back of the
subject hand using a suitably strong
epoxy the reason for this will become
apparent later instead this is written
as CP 963 - 1 is now hung by a chain
from the subjects neck 963 - one is not
allowed to be hidden upon the subjects
body and the attempt to do so will be
met with lethal force
second thing that scored out on this
document is if the current D level
subject exceeds a 30-day lifespan there
to be executed and a new subject chosen
to wear 960 3-1 again this will become
apparent instead this is written I order
a whole fight anybody 960 3-1 is
installed upon is given a stay of
execution until it passes on of natural
causes or 963 - one is transferred to a
new house the next two paragraphs have
been rescinded by oh five six eight and
nine but what was written before this
was attention as of 1213 963 - one is
not allowed in proximity of any Euclid
or Keter class humanoid SC piece I don't
want to hear any complaining about my
pronunciation of that word this
directive is to be enforced lethally
second one reads attention as of
incident 239 be clef kondraki scp-963 -
one is not allowed at site 17 without
the express permission of 3:05
violations are to be met with lethal
force at this point you do not have the
security clearance necessary to know why
these things were rescinded
moving on description scp-963 - one is
an ornate amulet approximately 15
centimeters in circumference made from
white gold with 13 k brilliant diamond
surrounding k oval cut ruby and
starburst pattern it was first
discovered in the personal effect
it would be found dead by apparent
suicide surrounded by a number of
supernaturally related books our agent
in the area found that 963 - 1 was
incapable of being damaged and brought
it in according to protocol xlr8 are
definitely dr. Jack bright a junior
staff researcher of Good Standing was
assigned to the responsibility of
researching scp-963 - ones capabilities
and granted access later that year SCP
76 - - broke containment see document 76
- 2 - 19 a leading to deaths and the
casualties
dr. bright was transporting scp-963 -
one by hand asked SCP 76 - 2's
containment unit and was among the first
kib killing bridge approximately days
later d1 113 tasked to clear the area of
rubble discovered 963 - 1 among the
wreckage and picked it up and median
noticeable change came over d1 113
interview followed this is interview log
X data recording
could you please tell me your name it's
Jack bright you know damn well it is I
believe you were Tom higly working for
us as part of your life sentence
ridiculous 960 3-1 is removed at this
time from d11 13s possession further MRI
shows that deep 1 113 ceases all higher
brain functions scp-963 - one is
returned upon which brain function
returns
dr. bright what we appear to have a
problem after much experimentation it
has been discovered that when any living
anthropoid comes into direct skin
contact with scp-963 - 1 the mind of the
subject is white and that if dr. bright
is projected from 963 - 1 onto the
subject it is known that the memories
native to dr. bright transfer from host
to host if the subject maintains contact
for 30 days their brain functions become
a duplicate of the lake dr. Bronx if 963
- 1 is removed after this time period
the subject retains an independent copy
of the consciousness of Jack Brant
sanctions were put in place to prevent
multiple instances of dr. bright from
being created to prevent dr. bright from
collaborating with himself however it
was found that this was not necessary as
dr. bread has proven thoroughly
dedicated to the foundation and its
cause
dr. bright himself has performed
extensive experimentation on scp-963 -
one with the expressed desire for
release from it
interviews with dr. bright indicate that
killed himself in the process of
empowering 963 - 1 and therefore was
never able to slave his own
consciousness - the amulet dr. bright
hypothesizes that he accidentally
activated 963 - one's power by being
killed instead of killing himself as the
original creator had done now regarding
scp-963 - two orders were given by o5 9
to attempt to replicate at CP 963 - one
all attempts met with failure until 963
- - at which point
all information regarding scp-963 fast
food is classified level five and it was
attempting to access further information
about scp-963 - - without level five
clearance will be terminated
[Music]
more information regarding dr. brights
mental condition see dr. glasses
psychological evaluation
[Music]